hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where right now I'm allowed
to talk to you about the four hours that
I got to play of cyberpunk 2077 I'm
gonna make two videos about this I guess
I'll make more if people have more
questions
this one is a QA I took a bunch of
questions from you guys I have about
4,000 actually maybe we won't get to all
of them but I'm gonna answer everything
that I can so this video will be a QA
the second video will be a talk through
where I literally walk you guys through
absolutely everything that I did in as
much detail as possible because I was
not allowed to record gameplay full
disclosure before we even get started
I am super biased where this game is
concerned I'm just owning that off the
jump
I'm really excited it is my most
anticipated game of the year and always
was maybe in Doom eternal was up there a
little bit I will give you my genuine
opinions but no the hype is real in me
first question how interactive all the
NPC's could you talk to literally anyone
yes you actually can talk to literally
anyone in a way that is pretty similar
to Red Dead Redemption to any NPC that
you walk up to and this is the thing
that I particularly really liked and the
details inside upon 2077 or what really
got me anyone that you walk up to if you
stare at them like even if they're on
their phone or something and that's the
animation they're locked in they'll
eventually look up at you I don't know
why just tiny things like that when you
haven't seen another game do it just
make things so much more of us if they
had a lot of really tiny details like
that that I loved but generally you're
talking options for just the regular
NPCs and inhabit the world is something
like press X and they will say like
Hello
maybe that NPC will get mad at you it
doesn't start a dialogue tree they'll
just say one thing to you a way that it
is not like Red Dead Redemption and I
think this is because there are so many
more NPCs in a lot of cases is that I
never really felt to me like the NPC's
while living their lives some of them
are just walking around the street but
in a lot of cases in buildings they are
just sort of standing in a circle not
doing anything which is basically
because considering everything is real
time in this game you can be in V's
apartment and look out a window and
every call you see an MP every NPC you
see on the street is actually there
which is nuts and I only had one loading
screen and it was only when he slept
otherwise absolutely none even elevators
which a lot of games usually
uses loading screens had TV stations
running actually interesting content or
cool ads and they were really short but
generally considering how dense this
game is they are still NPCs who repeat
character models and have semi
animations or are not necessarily doing
anything in some cases in other cases
there was a bar that I went to they felt
super alive it's two NPCs that I won't
post you were talking about the upcoming
election there was an NPC in a bathroom
who was peeing who has a voice line when
he kind of rates you for staring at him
for peeing all that good stuff
Cody Gray said two questions are there
any dogs to Pat none that I saw
devastatingly second what's your
favorite weapon to use so far my
favorite what's going to use was a
sniper rifle that could shoot through
walls and shoot through cover to an
extent they couldn't have too much cover
in front of them like a closed door and
a barrier would probably be too much
that thing was cool and the way I got it
was extra cool it was by a I guess a
side quest that plays out a bit like
Monster Hunter there are these I believe
they're called cyber psychos these
certain bad guys in the world who are
people who have modified themselves so
much that they've gone insane and you
have the option to track them down and
try to kill them the one that I fought
was not like a terribly difficult fight
it was on this really open bridge but
the quest designer I spoke to said they
will have tears they will have ones that
are much harder but yeah I making the
choice to go and fight him before
continuing on my main quest got his
sniper rifle which shot through walls it
was very cool there were a lot of
weapons that I wanted when I went to the
weapons store in these building that I
didn't have enough street cred to get
though I want to know what that katana
feels like man I'm still thinking about
it Phil Correa said I always felt the
witches movement controls are pretty
clunky how does it cyberpunk feel in
this department
I actually agree I love The Witcher 3 &
2 and frankly I even played one know
that that many of us did and when you go
back and play The Witcher 3 Geralt does
feel pretty heavy
I find myself like trying to turn around
a corner and walking into a post so I
would clunk is a dramatic improvement of
course it's all first-person so it's
different but yeah no no clunkiness no
heaviness I did get to drive two
different vehicles and was happy with
them I felt like I didn't have that much
to say and I'm being told that they're
still tweaking them but for whatever
reason
that was the thing that I was worried
about feeling sluggish in a way that
like a lot of open wild games that
aren't driving games do tend to stuff
with the way the driving feels I still
don't feel like GTA driving feels great
so my review of the cyberpunk driving
would be like it's not like it stood out
to me like it's the best driving ever
but I was by no means offended by it
cool cool with it I do want to say one
thing that like is a side note because I
can't imagine anyone's gonna ask me
about it when it comes to movement
controls one of my favorite things about
cyberpunk is that you always have
control so if you exit a I don't know
what to call a dialog interaction and
the interaction generally it's because
you are choosing to stand up or get out
of a car or walk away and it is always
actually a button press for you to
choose if you want to sit and talk to
someone and get in the seat or if you
want to stand up and walk away this game
once in my four hour period of time
actually locked my screen under
something otherwise I always had control
over everything that I was looking at I
always had controller but when I was
leaving a conversation or starting a
conversation there were no cutscenes
that is supposed to be a cutscene that
gives you context for a time jump that
was supposed to be in a chunk of
gameplay that I played that was not
ready yet I guess so it wasn't there and
the only time that I had my camera
control taken away from me which again
the designer that I spoke to said that
this only happens maybe four or five
times in the entire game which I loved
was because it wanted me to look at a
drum but otherwise there there is loads
of stuff you could probably miss because
you have complete control over the
camera and I just love the amount of
agency it gives you by doing that you
choose where you look you choose when
you stand up when you sit down it
doesn't force you into doing something
to be able to start an encounter and of
course this is an RPG I feel like I get
a vibe from like certain pockets of the
internet that they think that this is
GTA in a cyberpunk world this is an RPG
there is tons of dialogue your character
is very customizable I spent way more
time talking then I spent shooting so
yes much more like The Witcher who've
been like Grand Theft Auto I know I know
that's gonna sound like it's a stupid
thing that I even have to say to a lot
of you but I do feel like a lot of
people are expecting GTA and this is not
GTA no cops are gonna come after you if
you hit a pedestrian frankly bandura
said Ilana genital customization talk to
me I'm glad you are
yes there is genital customization I did
get to go through the character creator
I tried to cut it short because I knew I
could have spent a lot of time there I
love a character creator so I didn't
actually customize absolutely everything
but like you can customize stuff like
teeth I've never played a game when you
customize teeth before but yes let's
talk genitals went far enough through
the video that YouTube shouldn't be too
mad at me for saying these just medical
terms you can choose between a vagina a
circumcised penis and an uncircumcised
penis there was then a slide up directly
below that for penis size
it was grayed out for this demo I was
not able to change penis size or
experiment with the options the chest
size slider was similarly grayed out Joe
Barry said does silence gun flip gunplay
feel like it has any weight yeah I was
satisfied with the gunplay particularly
liked the stealth and I feel like I will
do the thing where I perched most things
with stealth in mind you can get through
a lot of encounters without killing
anyone at all
I would suggest investing in the tech
skill if you want to do that but one of
the quests that I played had like seven
different outcomes and mine I managed to
get one of the gangs to end up on my
side even though our first interaction
was really hostile so they were fighting
with me against military is one of the
two major mega corporations in the game
and there was a room where I was trying
to use my sniper rifle and failing
naturally where everyone just took
everyone else out and the gang leader
who would have been my sort of mini boss
fight in that level because I befriended
him was the mini boss fight for military
the exact guy that I would have fought
fighting someone else which was really
cool but yes I really liked the shotgun
I really liked the sound design of the
shotgun it almost felt like I was
shooting just a really brutal taser like
an exceptionally brutal taser I like the
way weapons look when scoped that design
is very cool and getting head shots is
satisfying in terms of feel I actually
felt like the pistol I was using felt
the best but when the other two were a
sniper rifle that can see through walls
and a shotgun that shoots like some kind
of electricity like bolts I don't even
know if it was or if it just felt that
way no bad no fat I feel like I am more
to the dialogue and the world and the
themes that I am to the combat and I
expected that from the jump but feels
good Phoenix King asks what does your
level with a weapon have on gameplay if
you have a low level with a type of
weapon example shotguns can you simply
not use the weapon or can you use it but
not effectively soldiers can't move well
with it or have difficulty aiming yeah
this is a really interesting one
actually so for anyone who doesn't know
the more you use weapon the more you
specialize in it a lot of games do this
you keep using the shotgun you will
level up your ability with the shotgun
but there are also perks you can unlock
that will give you like more damage with
a particular type of weapon etc yes if
you are new you will be slower to aim
aiming may not be as precise you will
literally feel like a rookie using that
shotgun Mila ah so there are a lot of
side quests and are they meaningful on
their own um I only I think I only did
two because I was more interested in
getting through the main story and also
seeing as much of night city as I could
I did one which was Jesse Cox actually
you Chuba Jesse Cox basically it was an
icon telling me to go investigate and
the implication that was that there was
some kind of penis enlargement surgery
of some kind that went very wrong and
his dick was on fire so he had me take
him to a river doc I got him in a car I
took him there I dropped him off he
called me later he was very thankful and
he transferred me some money it was very
silly and over-the-top and fun the other
one being taking down the cyber psycho
again I'm pretty sure that's what that
called I unfortunately didn't write that
death Town down wish was Monster Hunter
style I mean I also asked are there any
crafting systems yes but they were not
in the demo so I can't speak to them at
all sadly and three please tell us about
the romance options and how they work -
like can I have a robot boyfriend I only
or that I know of only met one romance
herbal character who I was very into and
would definitely romance so I was extra
nice to her even though I knew obviously
what I played of this demo was gonna
burn to the ground
her name was Judy Julie and I actually
can't speak to how the systems of
romancing characters works but I can
tell you that you will be limited by
your body type so say if you're trying
to romance some
who was only interested in someone who
has a vagina and you have a dick they
don't want it there are some games where
anyone will bang you if you try they are
just all romantic options no matter what
but these people have preferences and
you have to fit that preference which i
think is cool which feels to me like
there's a lot of replayability like I
said one of the quests that I did had 7
different outcomes plus there are the
three backgrounds that you choose from
for the purposes of this demo I chose
Street kid I do have a few people asking
me if I can kill anyone that I see in
the game like random NPC so vital
characters I actually didn't try because
I was trying to get through as passively
as possible really I never tried to kill
any NPC's I'm sorry Andrew Sepideh said
what we have first impressions a few
hours into the game like I said before I
was really impressed by that player
agency I think the world is so [ __ ]
detailed just kept walking around and
looking at stuff the people who designed
the back rooms that nobody's ever going
to go to and still meticulously placed
items there damn
the lighting is beautiful it is nice
playing a game that is kind of totally
serious but at the same time is very
colourful and pretty I think it looks
awesome at nighttime and one cool thing
that again I imagine nobody's going to
ask about so I'll bring it up here a
day/night cycle is one real-time hour is
8 in-game hours and you do have the
option to skip time because there are
some places like in a Shenmue for
example that won't open until a certain
time so you can skip time not any
mechanic by any means but it is the
first game I've played west skipping
time didn't give me any loading screens
whatsoever we just immediately go from
daytime night city tonight time night
city I don't really understand how they
did that knowing how complicated
lighting is in video games very
impressed with that one there's also one
thing that I feel like it's just a cool
touch there will be less or more NPC's
on the streets or cause driving on the
streets depending on what time of day it
is there are less people driving around
the city at 3 a.m. grey fox said how
does a shooting field compared to games
like destiny on titanfall it's not a
first-person shooter it does not feel
like destiny on titanfall I want to say
I feel like the combat felt more like
rage than it felt like
a destiny article which is also more of
an RPG David Rodriguez said does the
game run smoothly
yes it ran really smoothly but I did
have a handful of buts
none of this is cause for concern or
extremely standard stuff for a preview
builds explains the delay there's more
polish to be had obviously brand and
maximum said does it feel like there's
too much to do like does it seem like
too plain like bogged down by the
different parties available um I have no
doubt that there was a lot for me to do
even in that open-world but no I didn't
feel like there was an overwhelming
amount of stuff to do
like you know Ubisoft open-world game
where they just give you too much crap
it didn't feel that way however I do
actually think I will spend a lot of
time when this game comes out thinking
very very very hard about how I want to
approach quests and in what order there
were a lot of optional tasks given to me
in quests that actually often would
change the outcome of that quest maybe
in a positive way maybe in a negative
way something as simple as me sitting
next to this mob boss and someone
pulling him over with a gun and I
they're having a conversation I'm
sitting in the back of the cars v and I
have the option to intervene and to say
something on defense of said mob boss I
chose not to I was told that would have
a consequence so I do think that this is
a game where you're going to need to put
a lot of thought into every choice that
you make even into the order that you
make choices but it isn't designed in a
way that feels overwhelming it just
feels organic and the word I keep
wanting to use as player agency I felt
like I had a lot of control I also
didn't feel like I was the center of the
universe
I felt like other people existed and
were important even just an aside like
having played so much with the loss of
his pot too recently Jackie in combat if
I didn't do anything would like tank his
way through stuff like if I was like
trying to figure out an alternate route
or something he's just in there like
slapping dudes across the face
you can't also shoot someone to the
extent that it downs them it doesn't
kill them and just leave them on the
ground or finish them off if you want to
just so much player agency I felt like
it was my game and like I did have a lot
of constant choices but again in a way
that it was about agency not about
overwhelming choice or
those choices either TN guys said decide
characters repeat lines every minute or
do they have many different lines to say
in and out of combat you know what I
didn't hit anyone repeat a line a single
time if I took too long to reply they
would be like um hello so they would
sass me if I took like just slightly too
long to reply I didn't hit anything
repeated pyrokinetic how is the UI I
really like the UI in that it is
specific to what cybernetics you have
implanted so you can only see and you
would have seen this in gameplay
probably two years ago I think it came
out you can only say how much ammo you
have if you have the enhancement that
lets you see that in the UI so you can
turn stuff up photon stuff on buy stuff
to upgrade very cool michael Numazu said
favorite new additions to the game that
weren't seen at any reveal game trailers
before I don't believe we've seen brain
dancing in any footage let me google
that and make sure no it sounds like
people know that Brandon's is in the
game but that we haven't seen any
footage of it so brain dance is
basically a digital recording of a
person's experience in the cyberpunk
world someone who is then viewing that
can basically stream brain dance into
their own consciousness so you are
watching someone else's experience the
way they perceive it but it also picks
up a bunch of sounds that they wouldn't
have even necessarily heard that we're
in the location at that time and then
you can go into brain dance which is
almost like like using a sort of vo-tech
and experience a recording of someone
else's perceptions for a period of time
to make that a lot more simple and get
out of the lore if you want to read up
on the lore of brain dance it's an easy
google you'll find a bunch of
information detailing what it is law
wise but it functions like the memory
sequences and remember me
which probably not many people have
played so to get to something a little
more simple it's like the Batman
investigation sequences in I believe
they're in Arkham Knight it is basically
you need to find out a sudden piece of
information and I'm definitely going to
play the game when it fully comes out
from an investigator standpoint you
could maybe find someone who went to a
building that you need to infiltrate and
I is what I did in this demo there's a
record of them having
quoted a brain dance in that building
you jump in to what is again like VR and
you play that back so you get to watch
everything that they saw play out in
real time and then you can rewind you
can pause a Detroit become human did it
- there's a layer specifically for audio
there's a layer specifically for visuals
as a layer specifically for so say so I
in the brain dance that I did one of two
was looking for a certain thing that
would be cooled at a certain temperature
I was a chip that would only really
survive if it was cooled at a certain
temperature so I was using the heat
scanner while the brain Anse is playing
out and these people are walking through
this room to see if there was something
that would fit that temperature
description so that when I infiltrate it
later which I didn't get to do in the
demo didn't get that fall would have
been like my next immediate step I think
I know exactly where I'm going in that
room because I've already seen it
through someone else's experience it was
very complicated definitely took me a
little bit to get a grasp off but very
cool something we haven't seen before
there is a question The Witcher 3 blood
and wine
sort of touches on on this kind of thing
we have to take a potion that lets you
dream a fragment of someone's life it's
it definitely has a lot of power loss to
that the rubber ducky said other than
Keanu did you feel emotionally invested
or connected to any of the supporting
characters or even the antagonists I
asked because I'm curious how impactful
the storytelling can feel within a small
window of gameplay I was super attached
to Jackie off the bat to other
characters I just thought was so cool
and so interesting frankly yeah I think
one of the initial complaints that I had
when I saw some of cyberpunk was that I
didn't like the writing and I felt like
everyone was all like hey man get sucked
and it was just like a bit much and I
did note that uh on like a sheet for
them two years ago and it seems like
that shifted a lot people are a lot more
likeable a lot less some trying a lot
less hard to be edgy there is actually I
just remember there is a second
character that I encountered that you
can romance who works for military and
romancing her must be so difficult I
can't imagine she wants anyone but no I
feel like there's so much diversity in
this game so so so much diversity just
so creative to look at at all times that
everyone is kind of interesting but then
the way that the different factions of
gangs
express themselves physically is
so really cool to me you would have seen
that in some of those gameplay videos
we've already seen of course but yes I'm
very much into the characters that
populate this world Leo Cooper asked how
does Knight City compared to other
open-world games how do you tell is it
listen I hesitate to say this is preview
builds I only saw a chunk I was mainly
chasing the main quest I cannot think of
a more detailed open-world in any video
game I have played otherwise so there's
that again very interesting characters
but also very interesting stalls and
interesting ads burrito vending machines
the future is amazing Jack vomitted said
what was the most mind-blowing moment
when playing the preview um I just love
how and if I just found it so cool um
how slowly they dole out the law so like
there was this homeless guy sitting on
the side of a street that V had an
interaction with because I guess she'd
seen him before she was like oh you're a
veteran today he's like yeah it works
he's holding a sign asking for money and
so I transfer him money his eyes go blue
and I hold my palm out because I'm doing
a wireless transfer and you know he's
accepted the wireless transfer cuz his
eyes go blue the game doesn't say yeah
I'm ready for the wireless transfer he
hit me with the chip in your wrist it
just does that stuff consistently -
there's another enemy that that's sort
of like jacked into me whose eyes were
red when he was staring at me because he
was testing to see if I was lying I'm
telling the truth at any given moment
it's just a cool [ __ ] world there's
also just a lot of dynamics going on
that I find really interesting like like
I do a quest for a guy who wants me to
steal a car I go to the car I use the
chip the guy gave me to open the cop
turns out the car was bumped so no
matter what when I scan that an alarm
was gonna go off someone else was coming
steal that same car pretty much the same
time the cops show up they like bring us
to the ground and I'm mad at us for
trying to steal the car the guy who's
paying the cops off who is someone in
charge of one of the two main
corporations in the game also shows up
tells the cops to break our legs and
throw us into the sea but they don't
because the cops in most games are just
the bad guys you don't even [ __ ]
think about them the cops also hate the
corporation's cuz everyone kinda hates
the corporation's cuz they have too much
money and make everyone there [ __ ]
they're also from our neighborhood well
one of them was so there's like a
respect thing they recognized V they
know where she's been they know where
she's from
they hate the [ __ ] guy who paid them
to look off to his car - so while they
like beat us up and then throw us in an
alleyway they don't kill us and it's
just a lot of stuff like that that was
consistently impressing me while I was
playing through the game it's very very
very well fleshed out but it's even the
way that the tutorial for stealth and
combat and the cover systems and basic
hacking works came through someone that
I was in allegiance with hacking a
military which is like the military
corporation so she hacked that chip so
that regular people could get training
from that chip even that stuff is just
really well thought out I also love
knowing that in this world because of
the way that it is and because of the
amount of leaked allegiances people have
and there are of course people who
aren't members of gangs at all just you
don't have to be some people consider
that to be as bad as being part of a
corporation I never know who's going to
betray me ever and I did feel in a way
that I've never actually felt in a
videogame before that I shouldn't really
trust anyone I was very suspicious of
every single character and I feel like
that means it's taking risks with
writing there a lot of games done you
usually know who's gonna betray you it's
usually written on the walls from day
one they foreshadow that stuff all the
time in this world because it feels so
dog-eat-dog and people can get paid off
by other people so easily I was never
sure of anyone and I was also never sure
of who I wanted to betray cuz I had
maybe three encounters where I could
have told someone else something someone
said about them or did that would hurt
them and I was always thinking about how
do I want to play this so I know that's
not like me giving you like a box quote
mind-blowing moment but that's the stuff
that I think is the coolest about this
game that I think is what makes it stand
out from other games that is the reason
I'm really [ __ ] excited to play it
more than one exploit got a few people
asking about melee combat I did not do
any melee in combat so I can't speak to
that unfortunately psycho gaming said is
it full of cutscenes so you watched 10
minutes for every 10 minutes of gameplay
like every other game and it's dog or is
that much more gameplay and the control
has really taken away from you literally
zero cutscenes the whole time they could
have given me cutscenes
so many opportunities but they didn't
and I [ __ ] love that about it you
lost someone happens you fail a mission
or die I sadly never did I don't think a
few people asked me about Keanu Reeves
voice acting I didn't get to him I think
I was very close though I think the demo
ends kind of right before you get to see
him a lot of people asking if you can
end to any building I didn't try that
either you can drive pretty much any
vehicle same as GTA you just go over any
tickets not as easy as GTA where you can
pull them out sometime
you'll have to literally shoot them in
the face and take the call and cops
don't come after you
maybe they what if they saw you do it
but generally it doesn't punish you in
that kind of way
a few people asked me about the
verticality verticality is awesome I
think these apartment is like maybe 11
floors up in her building and you could
see 40 more but even in some of the
combat encounters there was verticality
so definitely something that they
focused on for sure Lukas McKibben asked
if you take full damage you do there are
mods that will reduce fall damage for
you and / Dave Hillier said how often do
you get to look at your character I saw
myself once in a mirror otherwise I
didn't see my character at all and I
think that's pretty much it
this is I've been recording for 55
minutes which is like maybe the longest
I've ever recorded outside of history of
course there are a lot of questions
sorry if I missed any major ones there
are some things that I can't answer
because I didn't try them I'm sorry
about that but yeah overall I had a damn
fun time you guys and I will have more
coverage coming so thank you all for
watching I hope this is helpful feel
free to ask more questions I'm happy to
get back to you as much as I can I will
see you guys next time
like